Here's something very interesting and gross
I want to be clear.
But we're looking at it from from a perspective
of electoral politics, the Trump 2020 campaign
and the 2020 Republican platform in the last
three days have confirmed and gone back to
being more anti-gay and more anti trans.
Now, the reason this is interesting is that
Donald Trump never ran as your traditional
socially conservative, anti-gay Republican.
He very decidedly focused during his campaign
in 2015 and 2016 on really an economic populist
message is right wing populism.
But it's an economic populist message.
I'll fix trade because trade and these trade
deals, NAFTA, China, the they're screwing
the average person.
I'm going to protect our borders and therefore
protect jobs for average people.
That type of language was Trump's focus in
2016.
And we showed we saw the effect of that during
the Republican primary of 2016, where the
evangelical and the Christian support was
more around other candidates.
Ted Cruz is an example.
I forget who else had early Christian support.
Now, eventually, the Christians came around
and mostly voted for Donald Trump because,
number one, they certainly weren't going to
vote for Hillary Clinton.
Number two, Trump started kowtowing to them
a little bit.
He told this completely unbelievable story
about how, despite being pro-choice his entire
life, he essentially met a kid.
He, like the friend of his, had a kid that
he liked and the person had thought about
getting an abortion and that made Trump see
the light and have an awakening where he was
now against abortion.
Totally unbelievable.
But he he played to it, said the Bible is
his favorite book up there with Art of the
Deal.
So eventually the Christians came over to
him.
But the anti-gay message was not a big part
of Donald Trump's campaign.
The anti-gay rhetoric for Republicans has
historically been a really great way to raise
money, even if the anti-gay crowd is not as
big as it once was.
They will still donate if they believe that
you're with them on so-called family values,
which typically include being anti gay.
So Donald Trump and the Republican Party seem
so desperate right now to stop the damage
that is being done by Trump's presidency to
the Republican Party, that they are bringing
back an anti-gay focus and it's because they're
desperate.
So Trump sees the numbers.
Women are going to Biden in record numbers.
Young people are sticking with Biden.
Older folks are going with Biden.
And the idea is, let's get back to the anti-gay
focus of five or 10 years ago and try to pull
in some people, particularly people who will
donate a lot of money.
So on Friday, the Trump administration rolled
back an Obama era transgender health care
protection.
That's part of Obamacare.
And what they're doing is returning to the
government's interpretation of sex discrimination,
according to what they call the plain meaning
of sex as male or female, determined by biology.
So this essentially dismisses any concept
of treating trans people in accordance with
their sexual identity and all of the protections
associated with that would go away.
The Republican National Committee has also
now called for just leaving their 2016 platform
unchanged and making it their 2020 platform.
That is a platform that called for banning
same sex marriage.
Now the timing, remember June 2015, the Supreme
Court said states can't ban same sex marriage
anymore.
So it de facto made same sex marriage legal
nationally.
That was June 2015.
The Republican primary was already starting
to get going then.
And the Republican platform contained opposition
to same sex marriage at that time, despite
what the Supreme Court said now, over the
last four years, as you probably know, even
among Republicans.
Public opinion has been moved more and more
into same sex marriage is OK.
This is not something we really want to fight
about anymore.
And the anti-gay activism has focused more
around religious freedom, not baking cakes,
that sort of thing.
But Republicans have decided they're going
to keep that as part of their 2020 platform
ban same sex marriage.
So understand, this is not an oversight.
This is part of continuing to counteract the
unpopularity of Donald Trump and the fact
that this is also dragging down a bunch of
different Senate candidates.
Joni Ernst.
Now we saw is doing poorly.
We're going to talk about that.
So they're going back to their old faithful
methods of bringing in bigots and raising
money.
So the same platform that they are reinstating
supports can so-called conversion therapy
for LGBT individuals.
The idea that typically religious type services
that they call their therapy, I don't call
it therapy, can convert your sexual orientation
or gender identity.
They want to continue supporting the rights
of businesses to discriminate against people
on the basis of their sexual orientation or
gender identity, which remember in some states
is already illegal by state law.
In other states, it is very much legal.
Now, there is some other stuff thrown in there
as well.
So in total, what we are seeing, you know,
Trump's 2016 campaign was an outlier in terms
of Republican campaigns.
There is no doubt.
But now in the face of polls that look really
bad for Donald Trump, they are going back
to the old faithful tactics of Republican
candidates.
Do the anti-gay stuff again pander to racists?
We're seeing examples of that lately.
Pander to xenophobes.
They're doing it all.
This is the strategy.
Pander to the worst of the worst hope that
the economy bounces back just enough between
now and November that you can justify, hey,
vote to reelect me.
And the third part of this sort of hydra is
suppress enough of the vote.
That along with pandering to the racists and
the homophobes and a slight improvement in
the economy.
You can get enough votes to get yourself reelected.
Now, remember, if we go out and vote in overwhelming
numbers, this won't work.
If we don't go out and vote in overwhelming
numbers, it actually may get Donald Trump
reelected.
Let me know what your thoughts are.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember, you can subscribe to the daily audio
podcast of the show on any one of your favorite
podcasting platforms.
And lastly, tomorrow night, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
The David Pakman show chess tournament.
Number two, a winner.
This is just for fun.
Everybody can play.
Skill level doesn't matter to sign up for
the tournament.
Go to David Pakman dot com slash chess.
It is free, free, free.
It's just fun.
That's all it is.
I will be playing tomorrow.
Tuesday, June 16, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
Sign up for the tournament at David Pakman
dot com slash chess The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.